RATING.
BRET?
>> Bret: PETER, THANK YOU.
NOW, TO CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
REACTION HAS BEEN POURING IN
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND FROM AROUND THE WORLD
FOLLOWING NEWS OF CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER'S DEATH
YESTERDAY.
TONIGHT, FOX NEWS MEDIA
ANALYST AND HOST OF FOX NEWS
MEDIA BUZZ HOWARD KURTZ
LOOKS AT HOW THE KRAUTHAMMER
STYLE OF ANALYSIS HAS SHAPED
THE WAY NEWS IS COVERED
TODAY.
GOOD EVENING, HOWY.
>> GOOD EVENING.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER WAS A
POWERFUL VOICE FOR THIS
NETWORK IT WAS IN MISS
WRITING FOR "THE WASHINGTON
POST" AND "TIME" MAGAZINE HE
MAY HAVE HAD HIS GREATEST
IMPACT ON THE JOURNALISM
BUSINESS.
>> LEFT WING COMMENTATORS
VIEWED HIM WITH ADMIRATION
AND FOR THOSE LIKE LIBERAL
POST COLUMNIST JEAN ROBINSON
ON THE SAME SUBJECT A LITTLE
NERVOUSNESS.
>> I WOULD ALWAYS GIVE IT
ANOTHER ---MY COLUMN ANOTHER
READ OR TWO BECAUSE I KNEW
THAT CHARLES WOULD ATTACK --
HE WOULD SORT OF PREATTACK
ALL OF THE WEAK BOYS IN THE
ARGUMENT AND PICK THEM
APART.
>> HE FITS INTO A TRADITION
IF YOU THINK ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE BO BUCKLEY AND WHAT BO
BUCKLEY MEANT FOR
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU COME TO PEOPLE LIKE BILL
SAPPHIRE WHO CAME OUT OF
NIXON ADMINISTRATION.
>> HE BEGAN AS A WALTER
MONDALE SPEECH WRITER AND
NEW REPUBLIC WRITER.
IT WAS KRAUTHAMMER THE WORD
SMITH WHO COINED THE BUSH
DERANGEMENT SIN DRONEL.
AND KRAUTHAMMER WHO DEFINED
REAGAN FOREIGN POLICY.
>> HE INVENTED THE REAGAN
DOCTRINE NOT REAGAN.
IT CODIFIED WHEN A LOT OF
SORT OF FEELINGS THAT PEOPLE
ON THE RIGHT HAD.
>> KRAUTHAMMER TOOK PLENTY
OF FLACK FOR HIS STEADFAST
SUPPORT FOR THE IRAQ WAR.
AND WAS VERY TOUGH ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
YET, HE WAS EQUALLY
COMFORTABLE TAKING SWIPES AT
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> WHAT SHE NEEDS ARE LYING
LESSONS FROM HER HUSBAND WHO
IS ONE OF THE GREAT LIARS OF
ALL TIME.
TO DO IT WITH A SMILE AND
CHARM.
>> AND AT DONALD TRUMP.
>> PRESIDENTS DON'T TALK
LIKE THIS.
THEY NEVER HAVE.
THIS IS WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
WHEN YOU ARE LIVING IN A
BANANA REPUBLIC.
>> HE PRAISED PRESIDENT
TRUMP AS WELL.
THE GAME FOR HIM WAS
PHILOSOPHICAL NOT PARTISAN.
HIS CONSERVATISM WAS NEVER
ABOUT GETTING REPUBLICANS
ELECTED.
HE RANGED WIDELY AS A WRITER
FROM HIS BELOVED BASEBALL TO
A CHEEKY COLUMN CALLED IN
DEFENSE OF THE F WORKED.
HE DICTATED HIS COLUMNS
BECAUSE HE WAS UNABLE TO
TYPE BUT RARELY SPOKE OF HIS
DISABILITY.
>> YOU ARE BY TRAYING YOUR
WHOLE LIFE IF YOU DON'T SAY
WHAT YOU THINK AND YOU DON'T
SAY IT HONESTLY AND BLUNTLY.
>> CHARLES COULD BE BLUNT,
BUT HE WAS NEVER NASTY.
A MARKED CONTRAST TO TODAY'S
ANGRY OUTRAGE, NAME-CALLING
BRAND OF PUNDIT TRI.
HE WAS TRAINED AS A MEDICAL
DOCTOR BUT HE USED A SCALPEL
NOT A SLEDGE HAMMER.
IN THAT SENSE, BRET, HE
LIFTED EVERYONE'S GAME.
>> Bret: YEAH.
HE REALLY DID.
HE IS MISSED.
HOWIE, THANK YOU.
LATER TONIGHT, 9:00 P.M.
EASTERN, A SPECIAL HOUR-LONG
PRESENTATION ABOUT CHARLES'
LIFE IN HIS OWN WORDS.
LATER THIS HOUR, WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ALL-STAR PANEL
LOOKING AT CHARLES' LIFE AND
LEGACY.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER WAS 68.